- You were also recently
spotted with Tom Hanks.
Does that mean that there's like
another Toy Story happening or something?
- Oh.
- What's happening,
- what's happening, what's happening?
- You know, Tom and I have
really become very close friends
from "Toy Story 1," he's a
very different person than me.
And he eats off my plate,
which I remember that,
I come from a family, you don't do that.
'Cause you got a lot of kids,
if I ate it, I wanted my,
so Tom's in the middle of the
first "Toy Story" and going,
"Oh, this is just so much
fun working with you."
And I go, "Those, those are
actually my French fries,
that's why they're in this area here."
He and I differ on so many things.
I adore that man's heart and mind.
And so now we're, it's
the most peculiar lunches.
We've been going to lunch
since "Toy Story 1,"
you know, twice, two, three times a year.
And we're like two older
women, 'cause we will sit,
almost too close to
each other, at a booth.
- Yeah.
- It's just weird,
and all of a sudden I go,
"You know, I think I'm gonna get up
and sit on that side of the table,"
and even Rita's asked Tom,
says, "What do you guys talk about?"
And I don't think I've
ever trusted a human being
as much as Tom to listen
to me and vice versa.
We've very different
opinions on so many things,
but he's gotten me to accept
his, he's really a wonderful,
engaging person, and he's the first guy
that listens to me and doesn't judge.
- And we talk about-
- Love that, open.
Yeah, to be open it's nice.
- Yeah, it's, he's a
good, it's nothing like-
- I think that's the
only way you progress,
and grow, and learn about
other people's opinions.
And maybe yours might hurt to-
- Listen, just learn
- Yeah.
- to listen and not jump in
as one buddy of mine said,
"Don't should on people."
- Yeah.
- You know what you should do.
You know, don't throw in
your opinion, just listen
and be able to walk away from that,
and go like, "God, I
heard what somebody said."
- Yeah, absolutely.